Ian Lake: Welcome to the development of Android models, where
We help you design better applications.
I'm Ian Lake.
Come on to work.
Let's think about how you can navigate the app.
You move from Main Viewer to Detailed Viewer,
Or moving among fraternal models.
Here comes the role of tabs and page viewer ViewPagers
What is ViewPager?
Is what controls the real movement between content pages
ViewPager gets its content from PagerAdapter.
This may be a comprehensive symptom
- one per page - or for all parts,
If you use FragmentPagerAdapter
Or FragmentStatePagerAdapter.
FragmentPagerAdapter saves each part
It is designed in memory, making it very fast when navigating
Between tabs loaded.
However, this may become costly, in terms of memory,
If you have a huge number of parts.
Which is solved by FragmentStatePagerAdapter
By destroying and creating parts as needed,
Save only the case.
There is not much about PagerAdapter
You must override getCount to restore
The number of pages you have.
Then, in the case of FragmentPagerAdapter
You will need to instill the getItem,
Which retrieves the part associated with each site.
Here we will just authorize a simple replacement
Choose the right part for each site.
But you have the flexibility to choose which route you like.
The other thing we want to overcome
Is getPageTitle, restoring a command that describes each page.
Why do you need a page title?
Well, those page titles will be very valuable
If you want to have tab titles linked with ViewPager.
Labels for the tab give users a good way to see
What exactly those pages contain without need
To move through each one.
This allows the user to jump between pages
By clicking on the tab.
TabLayout value, is part of the Android design support library,
Make it easy to embed tabs, in all material designs.
And its previous compatibility even Android 2.1
To tie all things together.
First, we need to link ViewPager
To PagerAdapter using the setAdapter
Next, connect TabLayout in one way
setupWithViewPager.
By doing just that, you get tags from the PagerAdapter addresses.
Moving between pages will change tags,
Clicking on the tags will change the pages, as I expected.
Start with TabLayout and ViewPagers
By adding a design library.
Be sure to check the design rules
And detailed training files.
Thanks for joining me here in developing Android models.
Use Tabs and ViewPagers to design better applications.